Twas the night before life day in a galaxy far
far away looking good tree food decorations coming
together heroes were to celebrate the day please
be okay please be a cape that's a wrap for ray
adventure called and she thought it would be fast
wow but there she found a key to the galaxy's past
what are you doing this is so cool we've seen
my master yeah my master's master concentrate my
master's father impressive my master's father's
master dipper or palpatine i don't believe it
uh you think maybe you could put a shirt on
it's a key to travel across space and time
i will change to the future so sure
are you less talky talky more fighty
oh so cute
you thinking what i'm thinking music a time
of joy this is ray a friendship a family
who are you guys master skywalker
my son i mean my these binary sons
you want to shoot first after you
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new star wars holiday
special trailer video that's right they made an
actual new holiday special and they're ripping on
everything everything that's ever been
memed in star wars seems like it's in this
so i'll explain what's going on with this and
all the easter eggs if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the mandalorian season 2 episode 2 is going
to be dropping later tonight my video for that
is also going to be posting tomorrow i'm also
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
because obviously this is meant to be funny
parodying all the different star wars movies
let me know what your favorite star wars meme is
on the video most of you long time fans know all
about the star wars holiday specials there have
been a couple easter eggs for the holiday specials
on the mandalorian series through season one and
even season two so this new holiday special is
dropping in a couple weeks on november 17th so
you'll be able to watch it pretty soon but the
reason why they're releasing it on november 17th
is because that's the anniversary of the original
star wars holiday special that was basically a
long toy commercial that took place between the
events of star wars a new hope and empire strikes
back because empire strikes back didn't come out
till 79 but george lucas wanted to hype up all the
toys that he was going to be selling famously he
made way more money on the toys from star wars
than he ever did on the actual movie releases
but the thing was is that they slapped together
at the last minute so quickly that it wound up
being the most terrible thing ever all the main
cast members like harrison ford carrie fisher
mark hamill were forced to be a part of it because
of their contracts for the star wars movies
harrison ford said they almost had to drag him
onto the set into his makeup chair kicking and
screaming he didn't want to do it so bad and
famously after it happened george lucas was
so upset with the way it all went down and
so embarrassed by it that he tried to burn
every single copy of every tape of it but in
the last 10 to 15 years they started to lean
into all the jokes and kind of accept it so this
is basically star wars making fun of itself but it
starts with yoda from the clone wars narrating the
trailer using the night before christmas poem and
the theme song is the theme from the nutcracker
but instead of christmas it's life day because
life day was a concept that they created for the
original star wars holiday special they also had
a big easter egg for that during the very first
episode of the mandalorian season 1 a big life day
easter egg i was hoping to be free for a life day
maybe even uh and speaking of john favreau because
he wrote that episode he also was the one that
joked at star wars celebration 2019 when they were
releasing the first mandalorian trailer that he
would do a new star wars holiday special at some
point you probably recognize some of the voices
here some of the actors from the tv series in the
movies came back to do voices for their characters
but not every single actor probably because
they're making fun of most of the characters but i
believe this is supposed to start right after the
events of rise of skywalker so you have rey coming
back in luke's old x-wing with bb-8 to celebrate
thanksgiving or the star wars equivalent with the
rest of the core characters from the new trilogy
but they have an ewok there's trees on the
millennium falcon for some reason poe's in the
ugly christmas sweater with bb-8 on it they also
have max rebo in the background in his band greedo
lando calrissian billy d williams did come back
to do the voice of lando they even have maz kanata
and zory bliss and even though this looks like
admiral ackbar giving lando a new space cape for
christmas admiral ackbar i think was supposed to
die during the last jedi so this might be his son
because admiral akbar's son was in the prize of
skywalker and speaking of mon calamari easter eggs
i believe it's the mandalorian season two episode
two they haven't released a trailer for it yet
but that's the episode i believe where they go to
mon cal the homeworld of the mon calamari that's
the part of the mandalorian season 2 trailer where
you see them walking around on that water-based
planet with all the corn around them that's also
the ancestral home of the quarren it's also the
episode where you see sasha banks character show
up so we'll find out who she's playing pretty soon
it seems like then rey goes to the jedi temple
it looks like the lothal jedi temple from star
wars rebels because there's all this time travel
like she finds a key artifact that allows them
to time travel through the episode so that all the
characters from each of the different trilogies in
the tv series can cross over that's literally plot
taken from star wars rebels if you didn't know or
you didn't watch that series there is canonical
time travel in the star wars universe using the
force it's called the world between worlds it's
sort of this inter-dimensional space of mystical
force energy ezra bridger wound up using it to
save ahsoka from the events of twilight of the
apprentice when she's fighting darth vader in
that sith temple that was the last time you see
her in the star wars universe until ezra bridger
went back in time and plucked her back out to
present day the entryway is also you'll notice a
big easter egg for the clone wars it's the mortis
painting from that very famous mortis episode then
they start the time travel craziness with all the
scenes from the original trilogy she goes back to
the events of a new hope with the x-wing approach
the first death star the trench run all mirrored
shot for shot from a new hope then they visit luke
doing his jedi training with yoda on dagobah
and empire strikes back and they start joking
about all the character relationships baseball
style my master's master my master's father my
master's father's master it looks like she's
fighting darth vader here during the events of
empire strikes back inside the rebel base on hoth
but it seems like they just keep following through
the events of each of the movies time travel
style just based on the way his helmet looks here
it seems like this is kylo ren from the events
of rise of skywalker the newer version meeting
emperor palpatine from the events of return of the
jedi and starts doing the ben swolo challenge meme
darth vader steals the key gives it to emperor
palpatine who wants to use it to alter the past
that's actually plot taken directly from star
wars rebels as well when ezra bridger was time
traveling through this world between worlds he
sees this portal to the events of the clone wars
emperor palpatine senses him through the force and
tries to enter the space to control it for himself
this giant battle scene with them all flying at
each other seems like it's from the events of
attack of the clones in the clone wars with all
the different versions of the characters from the
different timelines and different trilogies and
movies running at each other like you have anakin
skywalker versus obi-wan kenobi but it seems like
they've been plucked from mustafar before the
end of their fight when anakin gets burned i'm
sure there will be plenty of high ground memes
they also wind up fighting their way through
anakin's pod race during the phantom menace there
was a huge easter egg for phantom menace during
the mandalorian season 2 episode 1 last week
cobb vance speeder that he has here is made from
scavenge parts of anakin skywalker's pod racer
from phantom menace they referenced most espa
during the episode it's near their small town
where most of the episode takes place that's where
all the pod races happen during phantom menace
then they travel through the events of the
mandalorian series when ig-11 was still
active this all seems like it's from the events of
season one because mando still has his old armor
this might be the first time that baby yoda
actually gets a chance to meet adult yoda then
after a big montage of them partying everyone
gets dumped at the very beginning of a new hope
with younger luke skywalker and darth vader
joking about him being his son in the twin sons of
tatooine binary sunset that's what i was talking
about they do the blue milk joke and then they
end with the han solo who shot first joke with
old han solo from the new movies and young han
solo from a new hope so as you could tell pretty
much every meme that has ever been made about a
star wars moment every joke is something that
they're including in this so i'll probably wind
up doing an easter eggs video for when it drops
but it's coming november 17th in a couple weeks
on disney plus you don't have to pay any extra
money it's going to be totally free so no worries
but if you spotted any of the big easter eggs or
jokes during this that i didn't mention during the
video just write them below in the comments and
obviously my mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video
will post on friday just like normal as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see that when i post it everyone click here
for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
and click here to learn all about what's going
on with luke skywalker during the events of the
mandalorian season 2. thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!